welcome
um on this early morning I hope you all
at your coffee or drinks
to get you up and running
um you're here for a session on
instrumentation
in.net and Azure for cloud applications
my name is Alex thiser I'm from the
Netherlands and I work at a company
called experience and we help customers
move to the cloud in general and the
step to the cloud is um you know a quite
a big step
and the instrumentation part is
something that is often forgotten
so
with that we really believe that if you
have a devops mindset that it should be
all about you know the stuff that you
build and you want to operate and run in
production that there should be some you
know some feedback loop so you should be
able to observe your systems and this is
from the Microsoft documentation they
have a monitoring checklist for if you
want to do devops I've highlighted three
of the four that are there make your
systems observable and then there's
things with logs and metrics and that's
the main focus of today we will briefly
touch on alerts and notifications but
the first two are like the big thing and
the theme for this session
now okay let's say that you're the
devops engineer and with that I don't
mean the people that build the pipelines
but the people you know like the shirt
says we we build it and we we run it we
love it you know that we own the thing
and that's why we want to see what is
happening when we're building things so
you know just imagine on an average day
um you pick up items from the backlog
and you start working on it you develop
a new feature or something and that's
where you have your inner loop a fast
loop that gives you you know isolated
development and testing and a quick way
of going back that if things don't work
you can fix them but once you're happy
and satisfied you know whichever
branching strategy it is that you use
you probably
commit your your changes put it in the
code repository you'll run on the tests
from your CI CD pipelines and then
finally you put it out into your
environment so you start hosting it and
you might have multiple environments but
eventually will end up in production
and what I see a lot and maybe you
recognize this is that production is
just like it's there but we don't really
know what it's doing so whenever the
customers call you know your website is
down or it's behaving weirdly that's
that's where you're like oh I I would
have wanted to know that or at least see
what is going on so the observability of
your system is a is a big thing
um because if you can see what is
happening in your environments then
though there's there's a very rich
second feedback loop that is I think
essential for for devops
so that's where you see how your
application is behaving how it's doing
and you get a lot of feedback from that
it it might just be the errors the
things that go wrong but it could also
be Usage Now which new features are
being used and how are they being used
um so very valuable we need to gather
that instrumentation data like your your
panel with all the lights and numbers
that tell you how things are going and
if you monitor those you know that's
where you get your outer loop and that's
where you can see what is happening
there
um change things accordingly through the
inner loop and you know make new items
on your uh on your backlog if need be to
adjust accordingly with the things you
found out from production and it might
just be that performance degraded
because you had a new search routine or
algorithm and it turns out that it's not
that
behaving that as well but as well as you
would have thought you know CPU usage
might have gone dramatically up
so but at least if you know if you have
this happy developer you know loving the
devops stuff
and the reason that this is important is
um that especially if you go to Cloud
you
um you build your application in a much
more distributed way
and that means that there's many moving
parts and they interact with each other
and if things go bad it might just
escalate that's one side of the story
but it also means that you're dependent
on on other resources other moving
elements in your solution and seeing how
things work and where things are going
and where there might be bottlenecks or
things stopping or outages or whatever
that's where you need the um
you need something to help you tackle
that complexity of your application and
getting some insights there
the the area is called application
performance monitoring but it's not um
it's not performance in the sense of how
fast is this it's more about you know
how well is it doing so it could be
speed could be resource usage like
Memories
um the the CPU but also outbound
connections and things like that and the
things that we put in there ourselves
now to help you out there's a there's a
whole variety of uh of APM the
application performs monitoring tools
um you can choose whichever one fits
best or you might already be using
um today we'll focus on Azure monitor
because that's you know the the what the
session is about it's about it doing
this in Azure with all the tools
integrated into azure
all right so let's zoom in on that just
a little bit because if you build a
Azure based application preferably
in.net but that's not really necessary
then Azure monitor is the place where
you want to observe and see all things
and it's comprised of two parts the
Azure monitor logs and the metrics
the logs is where log analytics and the
workspaces live and the monitor for the
metrics is where you can get insights
this this is visible in multiple places
but you won't really see them as such so
it's there if you for example do a log
analytics workspace with application
insights and we'll get to that later on
now
the good thing is with if you have a
homogeneous environment with a lot of
azure elements in there is that you'll
get a lot of things from Azure for free
because it also outputs all the
information to this location as well to
these resources so for example your
Azure active directory any interaction
there all that stuff will be logged
there so you can find all the
interactions with Azure ad there
whatever happens inside of your Azure
subscriptions the activities you know
creation of resources who does what is
also put into that logs so you'll get
those and then with your Azure resources
combining resource groups you'll get a
lot of Diagnostics as well most of the
resources allow you to specify a log
analytics workspace
which then uses the same thing to the
same buckets to put everything together
so that's where you start you know
getting more and more application
specific
but you know as developers
um like I think most of you are the the
cloud applications that we build you
know that could be based on.net core
with new get packages and some Telemetry
libraries that you'll be using allows
you to send more just than than just the
other stuff and most of that stuff is
what I like to consider control plane
based so it's it's the interaction with
and the xs2
the resources are also about the data
and the stuff that is going on in there
so the the applicational side of things
and your application obviously is much
about you know what happens in my
application how many conversions did we
get in the webshop for example those
could be really nice metrics
um all right so good thing is that if
you take this entire stack you've got
everything covered in your application
from the underlying resources up into
the um the actual logic that you're
running and you can combine it and you
can you can see all the information
together
Focus for uh for today
all right so how do you do this this
application instrumentation so
there there's four parts of this so
there's logging
um that's recording stuff there's
tracing following stuff the metrics
that's numbers and there's the health
and now how are we doing so with those
four that's four things that your
application can do to provide richer
instrumentation
um so okay with this
um how do you get that from your
application well the logging tracing and
metrics are being pushed out so you need
to collect them
and then you monitor them obviously like
we saw before but the health information
in general but not always is being
watched so it's being pulled from a
health endpoint and that's like how is
the application doing or are you ready
to uh to receive traffic for example
now this this is um how you can do
things in the basis there are ways for
your health for example to push out
metrics so you can see statistics of the
health information being pushed out as
numbers
and you can interchange tracing and log
in with one another but that's where we
get onto a slippery slope because you
know you should be very conscious of the
distinction between logging and tracing
um once it's there you know put it to
good use and there's a bunch of things
that you can do with it so
um just to give you an idea obviously
there's a you know you can analyze
things see how it's going time series
and then see the trends there's alerting
when you know things go above or below
certain thresholds or occurrence numbers
that's when you want to be notified
um there's insights with dashboards
there's profiling if you really want to
dig down in situations where things are
not behaving as expected and the metric
streaming is you know with its high
volumes of metrics you can absorb that
as well
I think this is maybe it's a bit of a
crowded slide so uh you you can you know
work your way through all the things
that are mentioned there
but I wanna what I want to highlight
here is that especially the first two
columns are very important to keep apart
you know things that you log are things
that you might want to see a year down
the line and still go back and see okay
at this day what happened with those 20
seals that we had so important things
that are worth recording for a longer
time
it's it's sometimes used as Trace
information you know what we want to
know in a production situation why did
this algorithm not behave correctly
which things went in the parameters or
the arguments of a certain routine and
sometimes you know you do the logging to
to do the to find out what is going in
and what is happening inside so your
sprinkle all of your code with all these
log statements and you might do you know
say log informational or something so
it's not that important
but it's not the tracing part tracing is
about flow and and things calling each
other so if you want to do that then you
should look into the area that is
dedicated and intended for tracing so my
message here is don't misuse logging for
tracing and obviously it's a fuzzy area
so there's there's no strict rules there
but just be very conscious about it well
the metrics are about numbers so that's
a quantitative things that you output
and that you can measure and look at the
health we talked about how are we doing
especially in
um you know if you want to have alerts
on availability that's very useful but
it's also very useful if you're running
a kubernetes cluster for example because
it can look at your the health of your
parts that are running and decide that
it needs to recycle one of the parts if
it's not indicating that it's healthy or
maybe a degraded state and the order is
something different as well you know
that's that's the things that you want
to prove later on usually security
related and it's not logging so keep
those distinct as well
all right so I'll try to be brief in the
first part of the logging
um because I think you've seen much of
it but just to summarize so to speak all
the things that you can do with the
built-in uh corefx libraries of.net
um so the flow that you have if you want
to log something the gray area is your
application you will use a nuget package
it might be a different one you might
use Siri log or analog or something
different but the one that's built in is
actually pretty good I think and that's
your logging stuff that's coming out
it's a long message that you output it
has a certain category and it has a
level of severity
the login framework and then you have
log providers which sometimes confuses
me so what what do you mean log provider
but it provides a place for the logs to
be stored
and then you have the filters that allow
you to
tweet down the the various
information that is logged based on the
severity or the destination so you can
be you know have multiple providers
listening in on the logs and they might
filter in a different way each of them
now there's there's a there's a bunch of
the those that are provided out of the
box the in the new
um The Lean Startup that you also find
with minimal web apis or you know if you
do don't make six or seven based
um applications you'll you'll see that
the builder.logging is your go-to place
where you configure everything and where
you would register all the log providers
that you would want to have so that's
all the ads that you do at console at
debug
um and this is how you can set it up and
configure them and that's pretty easy
under the covers what happens if you do
those things is that there's a logger
Factory and all the providers that
you've added will be registered inside
of the log Factory and the log Factory
will create the I logger of T
implementations so I logger is the thing
that you can inject logger of T is what
it actually is and the t is the place
where you want to use it so usually the
t is a type for your controller class
for example
now
um yeah the the things you do with the
logger is you log things and you have
all the severity levels nicely
um given to you so it's from all the way
from critical you know this this is over
game over
um to um the the trace and the
information
um I believe the uh they're not in
correct order of
um the the significance but debug And
Trades are the lowest ones in terms of
very noisy so things that that happen
inside of a loop that is iterated many
times probably if you um if it would be
significant you know then you would do
trace or debug so that that you know
that it doesn't surface in just regular
logging because that would just float
float the the log provider
the um the severity levels and the
categories
um you can see the the real order at the
right
the hierarchical structure of the
categories is much like namespaces and
that allows you to be very specific you
know if things come from this category
this is the the level that I want to add
to it
the the the the string for the category
with the the separation and with dots is
determine if you use the logger of T
from the uh the namespace and the the
class name or the type name so you see
that if you have a namespace with the
web API controllers and you have a class
leaderboard controller that will be your
thing and you can choose at what level
you want to you know specify
how the what the severity level is and
for which providers it's configured how
so filtering those log messages
um like I said if you use I logger of T
it goes to multiple places every log
provider registered but you would
configure them in in probably in this
way so that's from your app settings
Json or any other means that you can
influence the the configuration system
you'll do a configuration of your
providers with this information and you
can see that there's a default section
that is just log level and then you say
okay for default so if that's that's for
everything it's information but if it
comes from Microsoft so Microsoft dot
something extensions dependency
injection
there would be warning but if it's
hosting lifetime that's the startup of
your asp.net core application or your
your worker service then we want
information again as well so a little
bit more information to see what is
happening
for each of the providers that are
specific and different you would add
you would add a new section that gives
you well in this case console so that's
with ad console you would log to that
and you can specify a different log
level same section as above but you can
tweak the values in a different way and
there's things with Scopes that I'll
skip on today but um you know you can
scope multiple log messages together
because they belong together and if you
so you need to say include scopes
all right
we'll have a look at that with some
some things
all right
let me see there we go
all right so what I have in this demo
and we will show some I'll show some
stuff now so we can later at the close
to the end we can you can have a look at
how to collect all this information
the
it's a web API with a web app and it
kind of looks like this let me just
start it again
so this is by the way the uh the health
check so if it comes alive we should see
that this is uh going green again
and let's see if it's starting up there
we go
we'll get back to that let's see if we
refresh this that we have visuals yes so
this is the uh the web API
um what it does it uses Entity framework
core to retrieves from high scores some
seeded values so if you try this out and
we ask for Json
and we execute it
we'll get this this bit of information
here that's to see the data if you go to
the home page and refresh that you'll
see that this web application is
retrieving the data and displaying it
here health checks are okay now so
application is running
so how do we get to that
that would be here
let's go to
program CS
so here we have the log providers I've
added the application insights so the
remember is for later on this means that
we're sending out logs to application
insights
we also add SEC and I'll explain that
later on and we have the simple console
that output outputs it there which you
can influence we know how do you want to
do it do you want to have the color
Behavior or just ignore that
so essentially we have these two but the
by using this thing here the create
Builder and I can show that in the web
app as well where I use the old type of
startup
where we have the create default Builder
now let me zoom in just a little bit
you see that the oh
let's try that again
there we go
so it says that the logo factor is
configured to do console debug and Event
Source in this line here so those are
the ones you get for free and if you
don't want to have those
you could essentially
if you start
configuring your your log providers you
could start with a clear providers
so these are all the things that you
could add you know the the SEC the
simple console system the trace but
clear providers allows you to start with
a clean slate and then you add the stuff
that you only want to have but usually
for debugging you know let it just do
console and debug and the uh The Event
Source would be just fine these are
added if you want to be really optimized
or in control then you can clear it out
all right then the other thing
once you start using it you can do you
need to get to the logger implementation
I'm showing here one strategy that's the
ilogger factory if you have that
injected you can create your own logger
and you can create multiple ones so you
don't have to do multiple I logger of
the injections and keep them all
together
sub-optimal maybe but also if you want
to control the category yourself if you
do a create logger without the generic
you can specify the category name
yourself so that's when you can tweak it
to whatever it is that you like
and once that you start logging and what
I've done here is um for demo purpose
obviously we're doing a log error log
warning log information to see how these
are logged individually and the with the
different severity levels and we'll get
back to these statements here and see
what is happening but if we
go back to this
to here and
run it just once more
then it's kind of hard to see because of
all the things that are happening but
let's just stop this go to the output
and then if we watch this just above
the things here
let me see
it's kind of hard to figure out with all
the noise that is there but I believe
that's there retrieving the score list
with a limit of 10 that's the info the
warn
and a little bit above that that's the
fail for the error that we wrote so we
see those logs appearing down here in
the debug window of Visual Studio
all right
now
believe it or not I I used to study or I
have studied physics technical physics
in particular so I had my fair share of
quantum mechanics and Quantum statistics
we learned that there's Quantum State
and Quantum state is kind of weird
because you know we're like a spin of a
a quark can be up or down
but it it's actually both Until You
observe it before that you don't know
you might have heard about Schrodinger's
Cat the experiment thought experiment
there's a cat that can you know inside
step on something and then there's some
poison so it's a really weird experiment
but it might eat it or not so it's
either dead or alive but if it's in the
closed box and we don't know it's half
alive half that so that's kind of weird
but as soon as you open the box You
observe and then it forces you in one of
the two Quantum States
okay A little Segway into how does this
apply to uh
messages and log messages I I like to
think of that there's the same Duality
you know it can be it can be both
um what do we mean so first logs are for
us you know we want to read and see okay
so we're retrieving something with a
search limit of 10. that's very good
that we can read it as humans but for a
machine if you want to do you know the
non-human side of things it's kind of
hard to look at that line and you
probably need regular expressions or say
something to say okay these are the
meaningful words and things and the 10
there that's actually what we want to
have
so you know sometimes you want one
sometimes you want the other and it's
you know and but it's when When You
observe it you want would want it to be
either one so you know and a lot of the
logs that we write are just textual
things so just just the the line of uh
with some string information but we
would like to have the other side as
well because we knew when we logged the
message that we pushed in
the limit that that was a significant
number to us
so semantic logging or structured
logging is what solved this problem
and you already saw this this line just
a moment ago it seems you know like
obvious it's like yeah it's just uh you
know a formatted string then with some
string interpolation but if you look
closely this thing the search limit you
know it's not a zero it doesn't match up
by name so it's it goes together in a
positional way
but the left side of it is the um
so the the string with the the curlies
that's the templates there that we have
the limit is the value and they are kept
in the one state and if you want to have
a string it's put together and then you
get the string so it's it's either
regard regarding your observation
now not every log provider supports that
the ones that um you know are are out
there and pretty uh used pretty often
are SEC which goes together with Siri
log but not necessarily and you have
application insights those are capable
of storing that information that rich
information and keep it separate and put
it together if needed
so let's see that
so we already did the
this logging here and just to show you
that it has this this template and this
placeholder and it has the limit
now if we start this running again I'll
show you that this is all in a Docker
compose
so in the docker compose
we have the composition of the web API
and the web app that's the moving part
of our application
and then we have the override that shows
the configuration for the web API
the web app
and then it says the database so we can
test with the database but it also has
SAQ as a container so we're running a
the place where we would want to store
this semantic
data it's running from this SEC
container and it's running at this port
5341 I believe that's the default Port
if you run this yourself as well so you
can run in an official production
environment but I'm just running it from
a composition so I can neatly test it
which means that if we go to to here
then if I just refresh this
or do it like this or we go to the to
the thing here we have this and then we
can say okay so we were looking for the
the log that said retrieving and these
are the ones that we have let's create
one with the difference the value
so we can see that up here as well
so let's say 42
all right
see 42 three times you see the Dots here
for um the um the severity level where
you can filter and just pick out the
ones that are warnings uh errors or both
but if you open up one of these you'll
see that there's a lot of metadata
attached and this one is
the one that we're looking for so this
this surge limit of 42 that's where we
can say all right so we want to have
this search limit and it knows that it's
a semantic thing so bigger than 10
and you can see that it filters out
based on the search limit
and now the the tricky part is once you
have this in place is to find the right
terms because this can search across
multiple log messages of div in
different locations so wherever search
name it appears this will just you know
find it even if there's more information
there it knows where it is so I think
this is extremely powerful if you want
to drill down and dig into and if you
have domain terms like conversion or you
know a customer ID that might be
relevant this is what will help you find
that semantic information and correlate
it all together in search queries
now and for the logging
um you know keep your logging uh
separate application should not be where
be aware of the um the log providers
that are out there and you should just
say this is what I want to say with this
severity for this category and your log
providers and the filtering will take
care of the rest you shouldn't make any
assumptions there
um the other thing your lock severity
level
what would you think
um if you had an exception you know you
do a try catch and you do a log inside
of there just think for a second what
severity level will you do
and you might think well usually I see
in all the samples it's like uh catch
something logger DOT log error because
we have an error right but it means that
something is really happening in your
application and if you have alerts
trigger to okay if there's errors in our
application we need to know about it but
catching something in a you know um
in a way that we predict might just be
informational or or even lower like okay
we took care of it you know we caught it
it's all fine so be wary of the severity
level and choose it carefully because as
a devops person you might be paid with
page Judy victorops or whatever tool you
have for on-call
moments that you'll get you know oh man
okay so it's catching all the timeouts
because sometimes the connection is slow
to this other thing that we're calling
all right
now
logging we covered logging then the next
part is about tracing
tracing there's two sides that I would
like to highlight that's the the stuff
that you probably already saw from the
very very beginning of.net and then
there's new stuff that has been
introduced in.net 5 and onwards so I
call it the good old diagnostic Trace is
where you don't just do a logger log but
it's Trace
um dot debug or write debug or you can
write stuff to the trace
with tracing remember that that's about
the flow of your application so you need
to indicate so this is what is happening
now this is where we are this stage or
these are the variables you can just
Trace everything and it can be high
volume
the good thing is that if it's if
there's no one listening or it doesn't
even matter but there might be someone
listening or not if if there's no one
listening it disappears because it's not
locked it's it's just send out like a
radio show if somebody's listening then
they can choose to do with the
information what they like
otherwise it disappears and it allows
for a publish subscribe pattern so you
just
put it out there you don't know you
publish it and there might be zero or
more subscribers
you'll find most of this in system
Diagnostics that's just like it was at
the very beginning and the two things
that you have are trace and Trace Source
Trace is the oldest oldest tray source
is a little bit newer and thing to
remember and we'll get to that is it
uses activities and that's significant
for our story
but the two sides is that with the trace
that's very easy to use because with
Trace you have these options to do Trace
error Trace warning Trace information
those are the three or you can do right
and right ifs and right ifs are
conditionals but it is evaluated the if
statement so it does take a performance
penalty
but it allows you to send out
information any place without having to
inject things so inside of a complex
calculation algorithm you don't have to
know with classes object model and all
the way down there you want to trace
something you can just say Trace dot
write and write out something very
convenient instead of having to inject I
logger of T and pass it around all the
places where you need to use it a tray
source is a little bit more modern it
has uh you know things you work you
control the the trace data you can trace
events which can also be significant
um that's that's
um you know another way of doing it but
you need to wire that up with Statics as
yourself and both of them have switches
so you can turn it on and off if needed
for a situation where you would like to
you know investigate so you can switch
it on and off like almost like a feature
flag
um there's a bunch of listeners out
there so where it's being sent or who
they're the ones that can subscribe
um you can see that they are available
from from.net framework 2-0 is what I
found and um the well.net core has its
own implementation of the the trace
listeners as well those are more and
more cross-platform so they will work on
Linux and Mac OS as well
how the activities
um that's that's kind of a cool thing
activities are structures that allow you
to have contextual information at the
place where you're in so it might be
call stack or information regarding your
trace and that's that's being
managed by for you
by the activity class and it travels
well across the various threats so when
you create one even if you do async
calls or you know then it will just
travel accordingly and if you ask for
activity current you will get the right
one so no concerns there
with activities typically you add some
metadata to it and then you say okay
this activity will start now we'll start
doing it from that moment on this
activity is like a little bubble and
things will happen inside of the bubble
you can spawn child activities and they
are you know related to one another but
um everything that happens inside of an
activity is is correlated to the same
thing so it has correlation inside of
activities
you can send out stuff that happens
inside of your activity so you can track
you know the the some particular flow
that you have
it even works distributed so if you have
a call from one place to something else
like we have from a web app to our web
API you can send out information along
with the call out there if both sides
play the game they know that they're
working on the same thing and a new
activity on the other side other process
will start based on the original one so
we can be correlated all together so you
can see flow from one thing to another
thing based on those activities and
there's two things that um that make
good use of this application insights
and open Telemetry so if you're into
open Telemetry it uses activities under
the covers as does the application
insights
all right
so I'll show that in code
so we can get back to it later
now there's one place in our API where
we can submit new high scores so that's
the scores controller the scores
controller allows you to do a post
for your nickname and your game
and what we do here is we have this
activity we set the start time that's
done automatically but if you choose to
do it differently you could do so we can
add tags to it so we can add the tag
gamer with the nickname we just received
we do our things so we we start an
operation on a Telemetry client that's
being injected from application insights
Telemetry clients being injected
and then we say okay so start an
operation for dependencies so we want to
you know see we're calling something
that is a dependency and this is the
activity that should track this
operation and then we start doing things
now this is a obviously a local
dependency to a database we can see
later on that databases are already done
at the Azure level so we can see a lot
of things there but just imagine that
this would be some some other thing that
you're doing that is a dependency for
you
in this case it's just Entity framework
core and at the very end I'm showing two
things so we're tracking an event
because if we passed all the way here as
we essentially received a new high score
and that's like ooh new high score in
the leaderboard that might be something
that we want to track and we put out
this metric so this number for the high
score
sorry
that tracks the value with the points of
the new high score doesn't really make
sense but this could be a sale in your
webshop and the you know the amount the
total amount of your sale and then you
could see you know what what's the sales
doing
um if you that is important
all right so
um we let's just
trigger this for a second so we can
perhaps see it later on so we'll do a
post here we'll try it
we'll say lx360 that's my
Xbox
handle and then I'm not sure what game
we should do we already let's do Galaga
and we have the Magnificent score of
one two three four five six executed
and we got a 200 so everything
worked let's do a new one
two four zero zero zero a big score
all right so two new two new scores
all right and we'll leave it at that
because that's kind of the the gist of
it it it's not more than that but you
have to do things for it in this case
the activities are also in a lot of
other places in NET Framework itself
so.net you know five six uh later on if
you make HTTP calls activities are doing
the same thing without you knowing it so
there's already a lot of these things
taken care of for you
all right now then for the new stuff
because you know the this this is what
you will easily find a little bit more
obscure but all the more powerful is uh
the the new system Diagnostics tracing
so we just talked about system
Diagnostics Trace which is a class this
is tracing and namespace and inside of
it you'll find a bunch of stuff but two
important ones are Event Source and
event counter
and event sources you know can think of
it of the tracing and logging side and
the counter is about the metrics
now if you put this inside of your.net
application and we're talking.net 5 and
Up
it will use an event pipe to push that
out so event pipes are something similar
to what is a for ltting or event tracing
for Windows etw that that's your conduit
out of your application to somewhere
else out of process
the event pipe is cross-platform so the
it doesn't tie you like etw does to
Windows or LTT that's Linux based it
works even for Mac OS so event pipes are
a good thing you'll probably not
interact with the event pipes directly
just know that under the covers they are
there
and then you have your consumer so again
you know it's it's kind of in the
tracing and emitting thing so you'll
have consumers a couple of obvious ones
application insights and you have.net
tooling for
nettrace.netcounters.net monitor but
those can pick up all these things
streaming out that you're emitting with
Event Source and event counter
if you would like to and if there's any
reason you could do it in proc as well
so you can have your own event listener
and listen in on your own events and
maybe use it for health information or
some other thing that you come up with
so this is um the way it works but focus
on the left with Event Source and event
counter
now the the event counters
um they they are a bit like performance
counters but that's again Windows based
this is more cross-platform
and in.net in the runtime you know the
CLR there's there's already a lot of
things in there this is just one section
system runtime and you can see what is
going on in there so the the obvious
ones are CPU usage and the the garbage
collection related stuff so you can see
what is going there you're working set
that's the amount of memory that you're
consuming so you can see you know are we
like climbing and maybe have a memory
leak you could already view that with
these things and those are available out
of the box all of your.net applications
from.net 5 onwards already had this
maybe without you knowing it
you can create your own counters
um it's it's not that difficult but then
you can emit some specific information
but these are the ones you get for free
and if you want to implement them
yourself then you can use a couple of
classes you have the event counter and
incrementing event counter and the event
counter is about values so you you give
that values and you can see the trends
and it can do averages or statistical
things on a Time series so we can say
okay what was the Max and the minimum in
this side this time period what are the
averages the incrementing event counter
is more about rates and frequencies so
you can see certain rates of how fast
things are happening so it's per time
there's the this is where you write it
so you give it the other one the polling
counter and the incrementing poll
encounter are two different versions
that allow you to they will ask you for
the information and you can do some
logic there that's inside of a Lambda
expression
now in the example that you see there
we'll we'll cover that in code in a bit
the that's where you um
you see that you need to have a frame
event counter and do increments and you
can even write events so that's the
Eventing side of things but this is uh
the little bit of code that you would
need and then you start calling that
from somewhere in your application
so let's see that in code as well
and for this
I have a different scenario
so in this case
you'll see that in a bit this is a you
know a little racing game it's 8-bit but
it uses a back end that is a UDP based
socket server and it receives all the
information from people racing and then
it sends out
UDP package through sockets all the way
but it's at least it's doing something
right it's just five times per second
it's emitting all this information now
all right
so what is in here so the the most
important part is this event source
it's uh the game server Event Source
it's derived from Event Source you can
give it a pretty name which is kind of
like the category this is the name of
the provider that we're creating in this
way so this is something that we can see
happen or encounter later on
um it has the incrementing event counter
and a event counter and we create those
frame event counter it has a frames per
second the
um it's per second so that's the the
rate time scale and it has a nice
descriptive name as does the lap event
counter because every time you pass a
lab you will get a lab count that
increases just to show some things
and then if the race is started you can
write stuff so um write particular
events but this is another way of
writing the events and it uses the map
name combined with the message here so
race start at four is the template and
this the zero takes this name and it
takes it literally as the variable name
and the frame sent that's the one we saw
on the slides this sends out that
information so every a second this is
incremented and this is actually a one
but if the it's something different it's
a double value that you can add here but
by default it's one and we're doing one
frame every time we send this this thing
now it's a
it's a class with aesthetic that creates
a Singleton so that's this thing here
which means that if we you want to use
this somewhere in our code
this is where it would be so this is the
update method for any of you that did
game programming you have an update Loop
that's the game loop we're sending
frames here but this is the point where
it actually happens so that we do the
log that's the thing that we just uh you
know the the Singleton server same
friend
server frame sent and then we give it
the map name which was part of this
update and this class
now with this
we can run this
so it's building now
it will start in a second
all right
so it's it has started
I'll put up two of these things
we need to connect to it online you see
that something is happening here like
the it's the send out the game list so
it's really doing something
and then we say Okay login connecting
and if all goes well
timeout let me see yep
all right there we go the other one
let's connect that as well
connecting I hope that works but anyway
you already see the information there so
this might just time out let's try that
one more time
oh now it's already connected so already
logout okay anyway so
it's stuff is happening see all this
blue stuff and it's it's changing all
the time because here you can see the
numbers that are passing by and now we
go here and we would do something like
dotnet counters
PS that gives me all the processes that
are able to be used by this tool at this
moment so we will look at the counters
that are emitted we need to have this
one the game server which is
20364. so
then we can say okay which ones are
there so you can say lists
and then do it for a particular runtime
version well let's yeah let's run time
let's skip that
so these are the things that you have
this is for net core version 3.1 you can
see that there's system runtime there's
HP net core hosting but since
five and I'm not sure why it's still at
five but since five there's system.net
sockets their security name resolution
HTTP so there's a bunch of more stuff
not just the system runtime
all right now the other thing that we
can do now is
and this is not the correct one because
we had does anyone remember the number
let's check again 20364.
all right 20364.
now it will wait a little bit for all
the information to come in and if you
don't specify anything it will do system
runtime and show you all the stats of
the things that are there so that this
you can do with your HP net core
application just do this and this was
already there but we had some custom
stuff
um so we need to
um
20364 what I'm doing here is this
providing this this counter and the
other one that I would like to see is
system sockets and system runtime but
only the CPU usage so there's square
brackets here to filter that down and if
I do that then we can see that it says
system socket so it's actually showing
us so five times per second you can see
that this thing is going up because it's
five frames per second so we're hitting
that rate and we can see the frame rate
here but that's the thing that we
emitted as well is running there and the
CPUs is pretty low at the moment
so this could be you know anything of
your stats if it's calculation ngino the
speed of processing number of
conversions per hour those things can be
emitted here and this is now streaming
from here and ending up also in
application insights in a moment
all right so let's move on
I put this in for reference but there's
a way to monitor these kind of things
with Dot and monitor
um you can do that locally or in a
container and you can install it as a
tool as well but this allows you to
watch your things and if you look at the
API endpoints you can see that you can
get metrics there you can force a dump
um and and some information on what is
happening there in the logs um just as
an endpoint to listen into it from from
this thing without any additional
tooling
all right now we've done a bunch of
stuff so we did metrics we did tracing
we did logs we put it all out there but
how do we see it because you know if
this is running in Azure what what will
what good will it do to us well that's
where you say okay we want to monitor it
but also query and analyze it this shows
application insights but this is equally
true if you have any of the other APM
tools and the the functionality might
vary
but in this case I've chosen for this
setup where the Azure resources use app
insights and Azure monitor like we
discussed at the beginning
now what happens with application
insights you can connect that to your
web app your web apis all the
dependencies that you have and the other
stuff and the other stuff the more is in
Azure the more you will get from it
other external Services you might need
to do some things with the Telemetry
clients and help out with I'm now making
a particular call that is with a weird
protocol for example and I'm doing that
with a client library that doesn't know
about this stuff but you can help there
and specify what is going on
all right so if you instrument
application insights it will send it
there any dependency calls or HTTP
requests or other things that are well
known will be put out there any
framework core also plays this game
and then the background services are
just dotnet implementation so they can
be instrumented with app insights as
well
now you can do logging and tracing so
you can do Trace listeners to have app
inside straight listeners you can do the
logging that we already saw and you can
use the Telemetry clients which allows
you to write those events and put out
the statistics and the information as
well so metrics and traces
we looked at the start operation Track
event we saw those
now
and we had the new stuff right so the
event pipe this is just a reminder to
the previous slide but from App insights
you can send this with a Telemetry
module but you have dependency
Telemetry modules but there's two other
ones The Event Source and event counter
which obviously serve either one of
those
now if you want to use.net trace you can
use purview which is a low level ugly
tool that's been around for ages it
works well doesn't look as nice but
that's where you can just see all the
information if you gather it yourself
with.net Trace you can collect it store
it in a file a.net Trace file and then
you can observe it yourself but
otherwise we'll jump into
application insights
so I'll hope that we can get to see this
picture here
let's just stop this
blinking stuff
we'll go back to our um
this I'll quit
and then we go here all right so let's
go into this app insights instance where
everything is being logged to it's it's
it's smaller so I'm missing the sidebar
but this works
um so let's see with all the activities
that were built in and that we were
doing let's try to see the application
map so what it will do now is gather all
that activity information and put it
together and then you can see this is
what we did just a moment ago you see
all the information and I'm trying to
get this in a view so that's the set
call that we made this is um this is
actually our activity got new high score
remember that we created that so because
it was registered as an operation as a
dependency you can see that it seems as
if we're calling something external
right so that's that's you can see oh
that's part of my my application we have
the key Vault calls we have the SQL
calls to Azure SQL and we have the call
from our web application front end which
was instrumented to the web API that is
here and this one is also calling this
thing here and if you want to have
details you can see that it's the key
Vault that we're calling there
you can see that if there's errors you
can drill down into them and let's just
force an error and I need to see if
we're still running the application or
not so
um
all right so there's also a live metrics
that you can see
live metrics
should be popping up so you see that
there's now two servers online two
service meaning two parts in our
composition or two containers in our
composition the web app and web API
they're both thought of as servers and
you can see that things are going
happening here and there are things
going wrong
all right so that's uh that's that's a
good thing that we can see it not so
good that we uh that something is going
on so if I do limits
and I do limit is one you can see that I
only get one but there's an intentional
bug if I do zero
it it it's in a very long Loop uh not
even a threat sleep and the front and
the sides this is taking too long I will
terminate this it uses poly for that but
it do it gives us a timeout exception
now in a moment we should be seeing more
things coming in here you see the the
exception that it just passed by
because that's being locked and detected
now for the sake of time I'll go to show
you a bit about the metrics that we can
also collect so we have log base metrics
um
the metrics that are there are about
availability about the browser that's
all app inside stuff but here we have
the custom ones so again you see this
this uh this frame rate counter if we
choose to see that and for example here
we had a bit of a difference in the
frame rate so a bit dropped to three not
too bad
um we could also um
let me see add metric
so we could also see what about this
this high score
so let's see if we already have that
average
it's giving me some data or not just yet
so refresh this okay that might be
coming later on we could say okay do the
last 24 hours because I obviously
tried this before
and then you can see now that there were
scores being sent in
um all right so this is just the number
of the score the average there we had a
very high score a moment ago
um then we have the logs
and this is where we can say okay we
have logs uh for example
um
traces let me just quickly
[Music]
um
to avoid some typing
all right let's run this
[Music]
um
the where operator field I'm not sure
all right let's do it differently we'll
go to
the logs
push out this get rid of this
and just say okay let's see
all the the
custom metrics I believe that's the one
run it
now you can see that there's a lot of
heartbeat state but there's also the
values of our frame rate for example and
there should be things with the high
score excuse me um also here somewhere
but this is where you can do the um the
the filtering as well so this is all the
traces
um but you can do similar things as in
sec to filter out the the semantic
logging information and get that info
out
in your thing so let's see if we if this
one would work
let's hope it does see there we go so
the race started that's because we
started two players and it's being sent
out and it has these custom Dimensions
that is about the map name for example
that was put in there so this is again
where we can filter based on those
things as we did just a moment ago
custom dimensions and event names
all right
wrapping up
so what we saw in this session
um is um we were able to do the things
with the logging tracing and metrics to
make our things more observable
um just a glimpse of app insights on the
richness that is in there but you can
get all the metrics you sort of graphs
you saw the log information play around
with it you can do troubleshooting
end-to-end
investigation and that's where it's very
strong the alerting is just a matter of
creating an alert say which metric
values boundaries and it will help you
raise alerts on availability from your
health monitoring or your your metrics
and the trace information that you have
that's all I have for you now we've got
these uh reasonably covered and um
I would like to thank you very much
we're out of time but I'll be here for
any questions and answers
[Applause]